[Music]
[Music]
my name's Jimmy come in manic and I was
born in joy even I started working here
in 1990 doing some t-shirts the two old
people's like the way I do some art so
they brought me to this print and is
this print one that you worked on yeah
it's a lady's art we had to work it on
Folkestone like copy the whole thing and
copy the colors we do like 25 copies and
what about the fishes behind there is
that something that you worked on as
well yeah the young guy bought it here
we liked the fish and fish on top like
we go fishing down here and there's all
kinds of fish like trout whitefish and
lake trout and tell us what are the
tools that we're seeing on the right
hand side we saw they couldn't even make
a horn the ice and the broken piece
would almost look like a spoon and
that's what you used to take the ice out
of when you've cut a hole for ice yeah
and we would make homemade fishing with
caribou antler when you have a fishing
rod like in the north it would be like
fries and he would break but the caribou
Adler won't break this young guy
discarded not too long ago his first
plane went all the way to Japan can you
show us some other it works
this one was penned by some lady that
passed away long ago her grandchild
bought the print here and we bought it
from her it was like gray color this
would like pencil but we use black paint
and we asked her if they liked art this
a year so we kept it do the younger
artists ever depict things like the
mining road or modern Baker Lake or do
they choose more traditional themes we
try and see what's going on in the book
I know they were making route to the
mines I did I wrote to the mines I was
gonna enjoy even and when I have a good
machine like when I'm going to joy when
I go through the slate and up towards
the mind and pass and I keep seeing the
road how it looks like and that's how I
made art this one one really good
[Music]